la lagune autrefois ce paysage aquatique
attrayant de l'arc de l'adriatique
servait de refuge à de nombreux
continentaux les eaux peu profondes et
poissonneuse protégés grâce à ses
nombreuses îles la population des
invasions des uns et des lombards
c'est ainsi que les vénitiens peut
plaire ce sol pauvre il y à 1500 ans
les moines y soigner les malades et
offrait le gîte et le couvert aux
pèlerins épuisé venant de la terre
sainte
aujourd'hui la plupart de ces îles sont
retombés dans la tranquillité et la
solitude
l'île la plus grande et la plus célèbre
est une des villas plus fascinantes du
monde
ce pont le pontet della libertà et le
seul passage reliant le continent à
venise le plus ancien serenissima le
plus royal
l'ancienne république maritime trône en
pleine lagune
celui qui explore la ville dans la mer
domb sur mille ans d'histoire triomphal
la promenade visuelle à travers venise
mène vers ces six quartiers verts
quelques îles de la lagune invite au
carnaval et à une excursion en gondole
napoléon dôme à la première station le
salon le plus élégant d'europe
son emblème et le lion et les symboles
de l'évangéliste marc
bienvenue sur la piazza san marco la
très célèbre place saint marc
autant du duché de venise la place était
un centre politique et religieux
aujourd'hui la piazza san marco et le
rendez-vous des touristes du monde
entier et entre pigeons et musique a
rendez vous pour les amoureux
les phéniciens ne connaissent qu'une
piazza les autres places sont nommés
campo
des procure à 6 enfin hors de la place
qui dès le xvième siècle fut le siège
central des fonctionnaires responsables
des travaux publics
d'anciennes et de nouvelles procure
ainsi relie l'est napoléonienne
l'empereur français fit détruire une
église pour cette aile transversale
une aura des temps passés entoure les
restaurants historique sous les arcades
ici le café-restaurant coadry
le mobilier les prix sont dehors
la vue sur la place saint-marc est
gratuite en face le café florian le plus
ancien salon de thé d'italie ouvriers en
10 720 il fut dès lors fréquenté par un
public varié et illustre entre peluche
miroir et tableaux méditerr que tu
marques tu rhein et marcel proust ici
furent échangés des intérêts financiers
et des déclarations d'amour
l'atmosphère nostalgique justifie le
prix élevé d'un café
on est tout simplement au florian en
était un orchestre y donne des concerts
là
ouais
oui
laissons en dormant flotte autour de la
vaste place saint-marc et se confondent
avec ceux de l'horloge du côté est
de noir de bronze sonne à chaque heure
juste la grande cloche
ils remplissent leur fonction depuis le
début du xvème siècle
le mécanisme de l'horloge était perçu
comme une oeuvre fantastique
au 200 m le clocher san marco et le plus
haut bâtiment de venise à ses côtés
l'impressionnante est fabuleuse
basilique une composition unique fait de
dalles de marbre deux colonnes et de
mosaïques
la première église saint marc fut
inauguré en 832 sa création repose sur
un vol des commerçants vénitien des
repères alexandrie et ossements d'un
évangéliste et à l'aide d'une ruse leur
firent passer la frontière en fraude
dans un fût rempli de viande de porc que
les musulmans ne doivent pas toucher
ce vol de reliques fut effectuée
notamment à des fins politiques
saint-marc devait renforcer la position
de venise en tant que puissance étatique
et prouver la force des doges ceci
surtout devant la rome pontificale
l'église apostolique de constantinople
servi de modèle pour san marco le
pillage de cette ville en 204 permis aux
vénitiens de s'approprier des trésors
inestimables
église devint un symbole de la
république maritine devenu puissance
mondiale
et
les célèbres cheveau deux bronzes
antiques faisait part des objets
précieux dérobé la pollution de
l'environnement les exils à au musée
depuis ce sont des copies qui ornent les
galeries au dessus du portail principal
au sud de la basilique une oeuvre
architecturale est un anti ben ali elle
paraît défié toutes les lois statique un
énorme bloc de marbre repose sur de
nombreux arqués colonnes transformant la
citadelle en une création filigrane
il est rare que cette pire simple
prennent une forme si harmonieuse
il est question du palais des doges le
seul centre du gouvernement de la
sérénissime à ce bâtiment de
représentation obtint son aspect actuel
du 14e siècle le premier palais des
doges bâti en 814 était une citadelle de
bois plus agressive il est prouvé que
120 doj y régnait et il le gère
4 noir voulurent s'emparer du trésor de
san marco et se donnèrent la mort par
trop de cupidité
que serait une ville sans ses légendes à
côté des statues en pierre couleurs pop
re on entre par un ave de portail
gothique dans la cour intérieure du
palais
la porte à des la carte mène tout droit
à l'escalier des géants où le nouveau
dodge fut couronné
l'enquêté statue colossale de neptune et
mars
l'appellation d'auge est en dialecte de
venise le mot italien duce en d'autres
termes un duc ou un guide au début le 2
j'avais un pouvoir énorme mais au 14e
siècle il devint de plus en plus une
figure de représentation un esclave
conquis avec honneurs de la république
disait le poète pétrarque
la salle de conseil du palais où l'on
votait offrait place pour environ 1800
noble
le côté 3 à l'est de la pièce est orné
par le tableau de paradis 2 tintoretto
dans la saladelle sénat tôt le sénat se
réunissait deux fois par semaine et ses
membres décident est de la politique de
venise
le plafond en boire 10 de la salle du
sénat montre des références baroque les
peintures du plafond proviennent de
l'atelier de tintoretto
depuis la vasque de sa main l'un
silhouette originale du palais des doges
se dessine encore une fois
à
un motif de photos prises et reste de
liaison entre le palais et l'ancienne
prison d'état c'est là que les
prisonniers voyait dernière fois le
soleil d'où le nom d'une ponte soupire
casanova vue vraisemblablement le seul à
s'échapper de ses salles de plomb
les toiles de venise a bien chuté depuis
en 1797 napoléon chassa les derniers doj
du palais
le charme de la place saint-marc agit
sur tous même si aujourd'hui les
responsables de la restauration des
monuments y résident
je
veni se nourrit de la lueur de son beau
passé ne vivent que pour la fête ainsi
fin des années 70 les offices de
tourisme et les hôteliers eurent l'idée
de faire revivre les mois d'hiver les
moines lucratif le carnaval de venise
une tradition blier vieille de 200 ans
fut ressuscité
le carnaval de venise n'est plus depuis
longtemps la fête somptueuse des
illusions du temps de casanova
mais les caisses des hôtels sonne et les
appareils photo fonctionne sans arrêt
les masques ne sont là que pour la pause
le show atteint son but
à partir de la renaissance le costume de
20 le deuxième visage des vénitiens le
masque de cacher les différences
sociales plus tard napoléon sévère
garant des moeurs interdit les
comportements fouet la commedia
dell'arte aujourd'hui les jeux et les
rires sont autorisés et quand les plus
jeunes en ont assez de la foule agitée
les plus âgés continuent à s'amuser
les billets d'entrée pour les fêtes de
carnaval privés sont un privilège
celui qui réussit à introduire les
salles joyeuse du palais est écrasé par
la vue des dames rococo poudret de blanc
et de se se prenant pour des jo ann les
costumes historiques ondulent au rythme
des sons modernes la fête du narcissisme
ce
changement de décor des boues décolleté
à l' architecture parfaite en bateau on
se retrouve à deux pas de lille san
giorgio maggiore et de la giudecca nous
visitons deux églises de l'architecte
andrea palladio
un
marbre blanc distri brille au soleil le
campanile et un cloître entoure la
coupole de l'église de palladio san
giorgio maggiore
la sculpture sur le toit par et bénir
les bateaux qui traversent le canal jo
des cas des moines bénédictins ordonné à
palladio en 15 165 de construire leur
église
l'intérieur baigné de lumière
impressionne par son architecture sévère
inspirée de l'antiquité
deux oeuvres tardives de tintoretto orne
le maître autel le miracle de l'esclave
palladio précurseur du classicisme ne
vit pas la fin des travaux il décéda en
15 100 81 30 ans plus tard l'église fut
inaugurée
du clocher on a vu sur la merveilleuse
cour intérieure de palladio
malheureusement interdite d'accès sur
l'île qtek en forme de faucille
sur la rive se dresse l'église du
rédempteur érigé aussi par palladio là
qu'ils adhèrent et d'instaurer en 15 100
46 venise fut de nouveau dévasté par une
grave épidémie de peste les dirigeants
de la ville promirent une église et en
charge et à la construction au génial
artiste de padoue et aujourd'hui encore
en juillet les vénitiens organise un
pèlerinage à l'église du rédempteur à
l'aide est un pont flottant
qui se déplace à travers la ville et
cela même pour le dernier trajet c'est
que le moyen de transport principal et
le bateau en plus de la plus grande voix
navigables le canal et green day venise
est un labyrinthe fait de nombreux
canaux et de ruelles étroites la vie
quotidienne se déroule sur l'eau
c'était le vaporetto il remplace à
venise le bus ou le tramway et se dirige
à eux régulière lentement vers son but
c'est pourquoi se déplacer à venise
signifie toujours garder l'équilibré sur
un sol instable
au vu de ses coulisses théâtrale ceci
n'est pas important car après tout on
tangue sur la plus belle voix navigables
du monde sur le canal est grande et
le grand canal long de 4 km et l'artère
la plus importante et serpents tel un
point d'interrogation à travers la ville
à son embouchure se trouve l'ancienne
douane la dogana del mar
derrière s'élèvent les coupoles de la
plus grande église baroque de venise
santa maria della salute est un
chef-d'oeuvre de baldassare longhena
cet ouvrage rend 10e vénitien de 33 ans
subitement célèbre l'église salute reste
à son oeuvre principale et occupe à 50
ans de sa vie plus d'un million de
montants soutiennent le gigantesque
édifice
il y eut une nouvelle épidémie de peste
qui incita le sénat a ordonné la
construction de l'église l'église devait
apporter à la vie la santé salute
l'intérieur octogonale est parfaitement
mise en scène il dirige le regard vers
le maître autel sur l'icône byzantine de
mari
les plus beaux tableaux ornent la
sacristie tel anciens tableaux de
l'hôtel de keats yann samar trônant
entre saint sébastien saint damien saint
côme et saint roch
de son contemporain tintoretto nous
provient les noces cannes à 2,15 161
riche en détails et en grand format
la peinture du plafond dans la sacristie
est également une oeuvre de tidiane kane
et abel on est un thème comme david et
goliath et l'offrande abraham
une vue panoramique vers l'église salute
ouvre l'excursion sur le canal et gran d
en face du côté opposé la maison dans
laquelle d'ester mona selon la légende
épousa le jaloux othello
le palazzo gritti une construction en
briques aux tic du 15e siècle appartient
à un hôtel de luxe
de l'autre côté du canal le pana de
sauver nell et des léonie devenu célèbre
grâce à sa propriétaire la riche
américaine et collectionneuse d'objets
d'art peggy guggenheim le jardin est à
lui seul un musée en plein air avec des
sculptures de giacometti mort et ap
c'est dans ce jardin que cette mécènes
et enterrées côte à côte avec ses chiens
doré peggy guggenheim acheta ce bâtiment
en 1951 et transférera sa collection
d'art contemporain européen à venise
elle légua le palais et la collection à
la ville
les artistes les plus importants de
l'école moderne sont représentés dans la
galerie max ernst avec lequel peggy
guggenheim était marié picasso et
vassily kandinsky
en face du musée guggenheim se dresse le
palazzo corner le plus beau palais
vénitien de la renaissance
l' architecte et sculpteur florentin
sansovino fihri j ce chef-d'oeuvre au
16e siècle
nous passons le pontet dell'accademia un
des trois ponts du canal et grande est
juste à côté se trouve l'accademia
l'école des beaux-arts créée en 1750
la base de sa grande collection de
tableaux provient de peinture des
églises de la ville qui furent
transférés des noms célèbres représente
la peinture vénitienne du 14e ou xviiie
siècle tels véronèse giorgione bellini
tintoretto tiepolo ou bien carpaccio
une oeuvre du peintre vendue tistes le
plus connu au xviiie siècle une vue du
canal est grande et de canaletto conduit
à lapproche qu'arlette sonico le palais
baroques commencer par balthazar et
longhena en francs tank autres musées
d'art un aperçu de la culture vénitienne
du xviiie
les tableaux de jean de pietro longhi
raconte avec humour et pertinence le
contexte et la façon de vivre de la
bourgeoisie citadine
les oeuvres de tiepolo occar et sonico
montre des personnages de la commedia
del arte tél l'amoureuse polichinelle
dollars également au palazzo grassi le
palais achetée par le groupe automobile
fiat est aujourd'hui un lieu
d'exposition renommée
les palets foscari et justin yann
derrière les splendides coulisses kotick
étudie maintenant des élèves de certains
instituts de l'université
dans le palazzo dolphin man in le chat
le dernier doge de venise lodovico
m'anime
nous atteignons le pont rialto le plus
vieux passage du canal et grands des
datant du xvième siècle l'architecte de
cette arche argué en marbre antonio da
ponte imposa le projet contre l'avis des
collectes elle pas radio sansovino ou
michel-ange
sur le pont rialto avec ses petits
magasins de souvenirs et de bijoux on
sent déjà la proximité du marché il n'ya
qu'à suivre les odeurs à travers la
foule et on y arrive soudain et
rencontre le bossu qui patiemment porte
les marches de pierre duo desquels les
publications et élus
le marché est aussi vivant que lorsqu'il
était le lieu des changes de toutes
sortes d'objets précieux et que les
marchands de tous pays s'y pressaient
c'est ici que battait le coeur de venise
des montagnes de fruits et légumes de
viande et de poisson s'y empilent encore
quand on voit le choix riche en produits
de la mer on comprend pourquoi les
vénitiens privilégie le poisson
je
la gondole nous conduit des pratiques
commerciales farouche des poissonniers
aux anciennes succursale commerciale
allemande en suivant le canal est grande
et le fond d'à-côté d'idées ce qui fut
créé au xiiie siècle et est aujourd'hui
la poste centrale de venise
l'hôtel le plus noble se trouvait
jusqu'à la fin de la république à la
cada most dans le bâtiment presque en
ruine qui compte parmi les plus anciens
du canal résidait en des temps meilleurs
l'empereur autrichien joseph ii
le palazzo pesaro de l'architecte
longhena fut construit en un demi siècle
il accueille les musées très visitée
d'art moderne et orientale
dans le palazzo vendres amin kahli en
face moureu richard wagner en 1883
lorsqu'il écrivit tristan et isolde le
compositeur allemand résidait souvent
ici entre temps ce palais de la
renaissance attire en tant que casino
divers
prenant le ponte et églises call si on
atteint le troisième et dernier pont du
canal est grande et
le fond d'attentes itoule qui vient de
l'époque plus anciennes benito byzantine
en 16 121 démarche en turquie en
ménagère et lui donnèrent son nom
vous
pendant quelques heures la splendeur
d'autrefois et revient le 1er septembre
débute la regata story crabe riche en
couleurs
il est prudente se réservait à cette eau
une bonne place sur la rive les ponts
sont en effet interdits d'accès les
vénitiens adorent leur régate que serait
la ville sans bateau
après le cortège d'embarcations
historique
les jeunes et les plus agiles femmes et
hommes montrent leur savoir faire
encouragé par la faute sur la rive est
dans la tribune
le spectacle est terminé on revient à
l'ordre du jour dans le quartier de san
marco à l'est du pont rialto aussi
sur le campo san bartolomeo animé souris
avec bienveillance des faiblesses de son
peuple le petit pea colonie du haut de
son socle le grand écrivain de comédie
du xviiie siècle critiquer avec
tendresse la vie quotidienne de venise
une représentation au théâtre aux
colonies ne doit pas manquer au
programme de bonne connaissance de
l'italien ne sont pas nécessaires grâce
aux mimiques et aux gestes les
événements sur la scène se poursuivre
dans les ruelles et sur les places de la
ville
dans la mer cheriaa le quartier
commerçant classique entre le point
bientôt et la place saint marc les
magasins de bijoux de verre et de
souvenirs à tire d'ailés grand magasin
de chaussures font ouvrir tel par magie
les porte monnaie et les stylistes
italiens réalise le rêve de vêtements
chics fabriqué en italie
et pour se reposer de se lèche vitrine
et un bar à tous les coins de rue cette
institution typique en italie n'a rien à
voir avec la vie nocturne on y trouve
pizzas sandwichs espresso cappuccino
limonade frêche
là
l'enchevêtrement des ruelles qui n'est
apparemment pas planifié à venise
s'ouvre souvent sur des cours
intérieures qui cache de somptueux
palais
tel le palazzo contarini delbo volo
l'escalier en colimaçon pittoresque du
16e siècle s'enroule comme une coquille
d'escargot vers le haut
ce n'est qu'avec de la chance que l'on
obtient des places pour l'opéra la
fenice c'est le plus vieux théâtre de
venise toutes les représentations ne
sont pas aussi célèbre que le rigoletto
de verdi ou la traviata mais aller au
fenice est un événement social
il n'est pas nécessaire à cette occasion
de se mettre sur son 31 mais ces soirées
appartiennent aux plus belles choses
secondaires
aux vénitiens studio en face de l'opéra
peggy guggenheim se sentiraient faible
devant les créations de soie plissée à
la foire tony
le vénitien linon l'ado expérimental
pendant des années pour dévoiler le
secret des tissus de mariano fortuny ce
styliste espagnole avait habillé les
riches dame de venise de doute issue au
tournant du siècle
dans l'atelier de lino landau le
mouchoir le plus chamarré devient un
accessoire précieux et élégant
sur le campo di san stefano une boutique
présente des modernités un autre genre
originaux sont les mannequins aux têtes
de doges
l'histoire de la ville est même présente
dans la course aux clients
au milieu de la place san stefano se
dresse la statue de l'écrivain italien
niccolo thomas seo souvent assiégée par
enfant et pigeons pour
un des derniers grands chefs d'armée de
venise le doj francesco mort aussi n'y
habitait ici au xviie siècle le palais
du même nom
les rondes suivantes nous conduisent
vers la périphérie à l'ouest du centre
les quartiers idyllique dont le son tour
au san paolo et cana radio rapproche les
visiteurs de la venise des vénitiens
un rendez vous prisé et est la fin d'un
méta delsarte est la voie sur berge du
canal giudecca est un lieu les plus
ensoleillées à venise tout fait
ans dominical dans le quartier
nostalgique dorsoduro
ici se retrouvent les ouvriers les
étudiants quelques magasins sont ouverts
après la messe on se rassemble autour
d'un verre de vin blanc pour discuter
même ici dans les recoins les plus
cachés on peut trouver des trésors
historiques tels par exemple la petite
église san sebastiano le peintre paulo
véronèse et ancré à tout l'aménagement
intérieur est enterré dans son
avant-hier
ses peintures de véronique est exposée
aujourd'hui à l'académie à l'intérieur
de l'église justifie la célébrité de
véronèse pour protéger son oeuvre san
sebastiano reste presque toujours fermé
particulièrement charmante atos aux
taureaux sont à place santa margarita et
les ruelles vivante autour du rio
tessanne barnaba ici nous les bateaux et
légumes de venise
on entend les marteaux et les six d'un
des derniers chantiers de gondole
sur les veaux 14 ce qui est au centre
ovin sont des bateaux mince et noir
attendent côte-à-côte d'être réparée
grâce aux touristes la gondole jouit
d'une grande popularité
les maîtres d'oeuvres créées de manquer
deux jeunes ouvriers compétent
un très vieux métiers menace de
s'éteindre
faire une mondaine est un travail
artisanal un bateau effet de huit
essences de bois elles doivent être
correctement sécher pendant au moins 18
mois un modèle standard coûte environ
100 mille 600 francs français
chaque patte au toit régulièrement être
contrôlés et sera améliorée sur un
chantier car que serait venise sens et
bandol
la proue est hérissée de pointes en fer
qui représente les six quartiers de la
ville la 7e montrant l'avant du bateau
représente ligne ou dec
la gondole gagne par son asymétrie en
vitesse et en hanovre habilité le côté
droit du bateau est plus étroit que le
côté gauche il faut être très adroit
pour manoeuvrer un tel bateau les
gondoliers vénitiens leçons avec une
extrême nonchalance au ravissement des
romantiques du monde entier
le plaisir à son prix si un bel canto
enivrant l'accompagnent il se doit de
donner quelques lits a de plus
là
mais
et
lemmens emblème de la ville existe
depuis plus de mille ans des lois de
luxe du 16e siècle les condamnait
rapporté le 2 heures noires jusque là
elle était riche en couleurs et orné
précieusement avec de l'or dubroca et du
vélo
terminus dans le quartier de san paolo à
l'église santa maria gloriosa déclaré en
abrégé eiffarie des moines franciscains
la fia construire c'est ainsi qu'à part
eu un exemple typique d'église d'ordre
mendiants gothique les doji les généraux
en chef sont enterrés dans l'église
farhi c'est ici aussi que le peintre
titien de repose en paix qu'il mourut en
15 100 76 probablement de la peste
à cause du danger toujours menaçant de
la paix est à venise une confrérie fut
créé en 14 178 à proximité de l'église
frari
les religieux de l'ordre saint roch le
protecteur des malades touchés par une
épidémie s'occupèrent des soins et des
obsèques des nécessiteux cette prétendue
écoles scuola di san rocco qui se trouve
à côté de l'église du même nom compte
parmi les plus beaux musées italiens on
peut y admirer de nombreux tableaux de
tintoretto
la communauté des écoles fut incités par
les religieux
des bourgeois vénitien face aux familles
patriciennes puissante sans influence
politique se regroupèrent également
jean était le patron de la scuola grande
di san giovanni evangelista
on laissa les peintres les plus renommés
de la ville embellir les salles de
réunion comme pour soigner une certaine
image à la scuola di san giovanni
evangelista
vitaux et carpaccio et gentiletti ni en
obtint la commande les deux artistes de
la première renaissance créer un cycle
de tableau avec les miracles des
reliques de la croix que l'on peut
admirer à l'accademia
les religieux de la scuola gardère un
éclat de la sainte-croix cacher derrière
le tabernacle dorer
les différents miracle en relation avec
cette relique sont les thèmes des
tableaux l'oeuvre de bellini procession
sur la place saint marc
dans le quartier nord ouest cannaregio
le rio della misericordia conduit vers
une zone d'habitations particulières
loin des sentiers touristiques là au
canoë sentiers sont plus claires et
larges au milieu de ce beau quartier se
trouve l'île de l'ancien ghetto juif
nulle part ailleurs dans la ville non
les maisons autant des étages lorsqu au
xvième siècle ce lieu de la communauté
juive de vins trop étroit les bâtiments
c'est les verts vers le ciel
le quartier était encerclé par un canal
qui transformait l'île en une prison les
quatre portes étaient fermées la nuit
est surveillée par des soldats chrétiens
aucun juif ne pouvait quitter le ghetto
en quinze 116 les juifs vénitien furent
introduits à la ou auparavant les
fonderies se trouvait la fente de métal
se traduit en vénitien ghetto ce terme
de vingt symbole international pour une
zone d'habitations isolées
au milieu du xvième siècle cinq mille
personnes y travaillaient
la ville encaissait des impôts élevés
qui conduire les juifs à la faillite
ils purent tout de même construire leurs
synagogues dans le ghetto
par manque de place quelques-unes se
cache au deuxième étage et ne sont
accessibles que par des escaliers
étroits
derrière leur aspect extérieur discret
leurs intérieurs son dieu surprennent on
peut en visite et 3 de même pour le
musée d'histoire juive
dans le coin nord rappelle des reliefs
en bronze du sculpteur français
alexandre blatt à l'holocauste de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
200 juifs vénitien furent déportés et
exécutés
ocana radio nous rencontrons de nouveaux
tintoretto génie de la peinture
le vénitien vivait dans cette maison
badigeonner en rouge avec sa grande
famille jusqu'à sa mort en 15 100 94
sa femme faustine à lui donna deux fils
est ce un crime trois des enfants
suivirent la trace de leur père célèbre
ils ne furent pas aussi célèbre que lui
la coulisse citadine pittoresque ainsi
apprendre pinceaux et couleurs
une jolie place où l'on peut se détendre
et le campo t che sweety en ce lieu se
dresse un bâtiment sacrale monumental
l'église des jésuites commencé en 1714 à
l'intérieur se trouve des tableaux
d'hôtel de tidiane et tintoretto la
façade baroque riche en décoration est
également un mihrab la vexer colonne
colossal et ses statuts elle est un
exemple typique de l'architecturé juive
l'église des jésuites et proches par la
voie sur berge au nord de la ville
les fleurs des magasins de la fondamenta
nuove font la plupart du temps le chemin
vers saint denis qu'elle lit cimetière
de venise apparaît en face entouré de
murs de briques rouges et deux cyprès
sombre
saint-denis qu'elle est est à chaque
saison un jardin fleuri les tombes sont
entretenus avec soin l'europe éternelle
est limité à 12 ans
après cela les dépouilles seront
transférés dans les tombes communes dans
la ville comme dans le cimetière du 19e
siècle la place manque
les tombes de l'imprésario de balai
sergey diaghilev et du compositeur igor
stravinsky sont conservés
dans la partie protestante du cimetière
reposent l'écrivain américain ezra pound
autant de la contre-réforme vivaient ici
le moine paolo sarpi qui défendent elles
à venise ouverte au monde contre le pape
ce incitations devint célèbre je ne mens
jamais mais je ne dis pas à tous la
vérité
seulement 1 km séparent les cimetières
de la voie sur berge forme dame est à
nouveau v de là on peut étudier la
partie nord-est de venise jusqu'au
quartier de castello
horrillo diamond i can't i la façade
renaissance de la scuola grande di san
marco séduit par contraste s'ajoute la
façade principale de santana polo
l'abréviation populaire de giovanni et
paulo ce bâtiment sacra de venise fait
plus de 100 mètres de long l'église des
dominicains représente un panthéon des
dirigeants politiques vingt-sept autres
furent inhumés entre le 13e et le xviiie
siècle dans ses salles sacré est les
prières des moines devait les aider à
trouver le repos ainsi offre l'église un
aperçu des tombes phéniciennes du
gothique primitif au baroque finissants
le monument dédié au doj pietro mancini
go montre par exemple le chef d'état une
première fois en héros trônant au dessus
de son cercueil les deux décédés
précédemment en furent présentés coucher
un tableau d'autel sur le bas côté à
droite dessins et des scènes de la vie
de jésus est souvent attribuée à
giovanni bellini
en 234 les dominicains obtenu toge
iacopo tiepolo de l'autorisation de
construire l'église les franciscains qui
en même temps érigeait l'église frari de
vins les plus durs rivaux en ce qui
concerne l acquis de fonds publics et de
don giovanni et parolo furent promus
église sépulcrale préféré
la gloire de l'église se poursuit en une
statue équestre sur le parvis
elle éternise le chef des mercenaires
bartolomeo colleoni en bronze décédé en
14 175 il obtint cet honneur grâce un
don important à venise
petit mais un des plus purs exemple de
style de la première renaissance
italienne est l'église toute proche
santa maria dei miracoli
en tant qu'eglise votive pour un tableau
de marie miraculeux elle fut créée par
pietro lombardo et ses fils entrent 481
et 489 des formes claires et
architecturale et l'art de tailler les
pierres de la famille remplace de loin
la peinture celle ci étant réservé aux
plafonds à caissons richement décorés
l'apparition de la mère de dieu donne à
leur nom à l'église et à la place
santamaria forme ans à ce lieu fait
partie des plus beaux de venise encadré
de palets imposant tel le palazzo mallet
pied à l'autre et visa il offre aux
fêtes publiques une coulisse on dieuze
pâques était fêtée par les plus hauts
dignitaires de la ville tous les ans à
l'église sainte sacrias les religieuses
du cloître avaient le privilège de
broder les chapeaux des dodge
église et place place et églises venise
en poser tant que l'on ne peut pas les
compter l' isolement du campo bendjana
et moraux et d'autant plus reposants le
cari se situe quelques minutes non loin
de la place saint-marc et de la rive
saleh
alors
le son aigu du signal du bateau témoigne
de la rive toujours bondée la riva degli
schiavoni la voie sur berge à l'est
offre en promenade estimé autour de la
vasque de saint marc
les nobles palais sur lequel furent
transformé en auberge noble cher
là où aujourd'hui les bateaux bus font
leur ronde des navires de guerre étaient
mis à l'eau au 12e siècle c'est ici que
commence l'arsenal un des plus gros
complexe industriel d'europe près de 16
mille ouvriers montèrent des galères qui
menèrent les croisés de venise vers des
pays lointains
les lions ramener comme butin de guerre
protège l'entrée de l'arsenal
il rappelle la prise du péloponnèse en
l'arsenal fortifiée s'étend jusqu'à une
petite île à l'est ce petit lieu
idyllique avec l'église san pietro à
castelo était déjà un évêché en 775 ce
bâtiment sacrale fut longtemps
cathédrale de venise
en 1807 san pietro dû laisser ce titre à
la basilique saint-marc
loin du centre ville agitée à castelo
vivent pour la plupart des pêcheurs avec
leurs familles une venise plus modestes
qui pour cette raison justement exerce
ses charmes
jusqu'à midi une activité débordante
règne autour de la vie à garibaldi
on trouve ici des auberges simple mais
recommandée ainsi qu'un petit marché
matinal aux légumes et aux poissons
la vie à garibaldi est un canal
remblayer c'est-à-dire un ryo taira qui
prend fin à la vasque de saint-marc
point d'arrivée de notre route vers la
lagune
nous visitons le long et étroit lido il
protège venise de la mer et les îles
murano burano et torch lots aux lors de
la lagune
le lido mondain attire en été des
milliers de curistes autrefois les
riches patriciens et leurs familles se
laissèrent construire des villas d'été
le lido connu son heure de gloire dans
les années 20
aujourd'hui son nom est utilisé
communément pour désigner une plage
l'ambiance du tournant de siècle fut
capturée par loki nos visconti lorsqu'il
filme à le grand hôtel des bains dans la
maison belle époque il mis en scène en
1970 son film mort à venise
là où le grand écrivain fut inspiré se
dressent encore les maisons de pain en
bois ses protagonistes reviennent à la
vie
le rendez-vous des baux et des riches
ainsi que des personnes influentes
restent tous les ans l'hôtel noble
orientale excelsior
depuis que le premier festival du film
mondiale fut ouvert en 1932 au lido se
bousculent en septembre reporters
journalistes et plus encore des curieux
autour des personnalités ou se voulant
le devenir
de nombreux films star et fait se
tiennent alors au palazzo del cinema et
au casino ce dernier est en effet lieu
de jeu pour les accros de la mise
nous quittons l'île de la fraîcheur de
l'été en direction de morano l'île des
souffleurs de verre
les figurines couleurs bonbon qui tourne
dans la vitrine proviennent d'extrême
orient
l'ancien habiletés de morano fini en une
production en masse de tape-à-l'oeil
le métier traditionnel de souffleur de
verre débuta au xiiie siècle lorsqu'on
expatriés à toutes les vérités ne
siègent sur l'île à cause des risques
d'incendié au xvième siècle morano était
une ville florissante
les souffleurs de verre avait une bonne
réputation et leur fille pouvait même
épousé des nobles
il est possible d'observer ces derniers
artistes pendant leur travail
la visite d'une verrerie n'oblige pas à
l'achat
il fait chaud dans ces zones où les
fours atteignent de hautes températures
angelo savez y est habitué depuis des
années en seulement quelques minutes
comme par magie il fabrique un cheval en
verre
de la tranquillité reposant de morano
nous nous dirigeons vers la prochaine il
elle fut rendue célèbre par une autre
sorte d'artisanat jusqu'au 19ème siècle
les broderies de dentelle tout comme le
verre de murano étaient des objets
précieux
six mille personnes vivent sur l'île de
burano une île de pêcheurs paisible dont
les maisons multicolores rappelle les
coulisses d'opéras italiens
une tache de couleur sur la lagune qui
se développe pas en une célèbre colonie
d'artistes
les ouvrages au crochet pour marché des
magasins de paul anoh sont de hong kong
la réelle de la tante elle montre les
buralistes viennent au musée marletti
à la lumière du jour elles sont
imbattables dans ce domaine
cela explique le prix élevé de ces
broderies fine
dans leurs chansons elle nous leur
travail parle de leur amour pour la
ville de la lagune et des hommes de
bolano qui travaille en tant que co 2
liées à venise
le bateau-bus nous ramène aux origines
de la ville de saint-marc vers une île
qui se nomme maire de venise avec raison
son nom est au cello et une étendues
désertes accueille le visiteur
quand le soleil d'hiver à paris enfin à
travers le brouillard un chemin étroit
indique le centre de l'île
entre le cinquième et le septième siècle
torch et l'eau était un refuge pour les
expatriés des barbares
il il fut bientôt une ville commerçante
florissante et un évêché
debaty sacrale sont témoins de cet
apogée et l'église romane sainte à fos
cas et du début du christianisme santa
maria assunta
la cathédrale bâtie en 640 obtint au
xième siècle son aspect actuel
une mère de dieu vêtus de bleu couronne
le sanctuaire ses pleurs semble déplorer
le destin de torch lots
en face d'elle une suite image en
mosaïque faite avec art le dernier
jugement
un musée archéologique recouvre des
trésors de l'unique centre de la lagune
l'écrivain ernest hemingway adorait
cello il descendait souvent à l'auberge
chip yann
des maisons abandonnées avec le lion de
saint-marc rappelle l'histoire de venise
il est à peine croyable que 20000
personnes vécurent à tort cello
aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas plus de 50
la malaria et la peste dessinèrent
autrefois la population
démarrant sablé et les maladies
détruisirent la ville et créèrent une
nouvelle
venise